[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا هذه الحلقه من
مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
كابتن في شرم الشيخ يضع الدول المتقدمه
تحت الضغط
[موسيقى]
وما هي التناقضات التي
تلمحها السعوديه في الخطاب الاوروبي
المعادي للوقود الاحفوري
[موسيقى]
من اتيح له حضور مؤتمر الامم المتحده
للمناخ كوب 216 في كلاسكو العامل الماضي
وكوب 22 في شرم الشيخ هذا العام يلاحظوا
تغيرا كبيرا في الخطاب والاولويات العام
الماضي كان الضغط كبيرا من الدول المتقدمه
على الدول الناميه لرفع مستهدفاتها
المناخيه وتقديم تعهدات اكبر للحياه
الصفري اما هذا العام فتبدوا الصوره
مختلفه بعض الشيء فالصوت الاعلى للدول
الناميه التي تطالب الدول المتقدمه بتنفيذ
تعهداتها بتقديم التمويل لعمليه تحول
الطاقه ورفع قدرات التكيف اضافه الى تقديم
التعويضات عن الخسائر والاضرار التي يتسبب
بها التغير المناخي
ما ساعد في تغير الصوره ان مؤتمر الكوب
يعقد هذه السنه في دوله افريقيه واللافته
انه يحمل عنوان تنفيذ التعاهدات الدول
الافريقيه مسؤوله فقط عن 3% من الانبعاثات
المسببه للتغير المناخي تاريخيا لكن هذه
النسبه يمكن ان تتغير بشكل جذري اذا
انتقلت القاره السمراء الى النمو الاقتصاد
السريع وبالتالي يمكن ان يتكرر ما حصل في
الصين والهند اللتين اصبحتا تساهمان
باربعين في المئه من الانبعاثات العالميه
ولذلك باتت الدول المتقدمه مطالبه بتمويل
مشاريع تحول الطاقه في افريقيا تحديدا
والدول الناميه عموما وقد لاحظنا بالفعل
حضور الفاعلا للدول الافريقيه في المؤتمر
سعيا للوصول الى صفقات التموين
في ملف التمويل نشير الى ان الدول
المتقدمه ذهبت الى شرم الشيخ من دون
الوفاء بوعدها بتقديم 100 مليار دولار
سنويا للبلدان الناميه التي اقرت منذ عام
2009 لكنها اعاده التاكيد في شرم الشيخ
على ذلك التعهد وعبرت عن ثقتها بان الهدف
سيتحقق عام 20 23 وذلك تحت الضغط مطالبات
الدول الناميه بالوفاء بالتعهدات
[موسيقى]
مشكله تمويل تحول الطاقه تفاقمت في ظل
انهاك موازنات الدول
الناميه بعد جائه كورونا ولذلك كانت
المبادره الاكبر في مؤتمر العام الماضي
لاشراك القطاع الخاص من خلال تحالف
لمؤسسات تدير 130 تريليون دولار من الاصول
ولكن هذا التحالف يبدو انه يضعف في غياب
الالتزام الحقيقي
سالت المدير العامه لصندوق النقد الدولي
كريستالينا جورج جيفا ان كانت هناك طريقه
من خلال كابتونت 7 لاطلاق اليه لتوظيف هذه
الاصول تحت الاداره وتوجيهها نحو الدول
الناميه والاقل دخله
هناك امرني يمكن القيام بهما خلال الكابتن
سيفن اولا زياده انتباه الموجه لتهيئه
المشاريع وتسهيل الوصول الى صناديق تعنى
بذلك للمستثمرين من القطاع الخاص بمن فيهم
هؤلاء من الدول الناميه وثانيا على مستوى
الدول للجميع القطع العام بنوك التنميه
متعدده الاطراف والقطاع الخاص
ولكن دعني اقول ان لدينا بعض الاخبار
الساره التي يمكن الاحتفال بها وهي ظهور
حجما ملحوظ من التمويل من خلال سندات
المتعلقه
هذا نهج ايجابي واضح العام الماضي كان
لدينا اصدارات ب 252 مليار دولار علما ان
قبلها بسنوات قليله كان هذا الرقم بعشره
مليارات وليس بمئات مليارات علينا اذا
الاحتفال لدى وجود التقدم علينا ان نسال
كيف قاموا بذلك وكيف يمكننا زياده ذلك
ونقل التجربه في اماكن اخرى
7 وهي بدلا من الحديث عن الخسائر ووجود
بعض الدول الصناعيه التي لا تريد تحمل
المسؤوليه بعض الدول الناشئه وتلك الفقيره
تدعو للاعفاء من الديون مقابل الحفاظ على
البيئه مثل كولومبيا الفكره قدموا لنا
اعفاء من الديون ونقوم بالحفاظ على
الامازون ما رايك بذلك
لدينا مشكلتان رئيسيتين ولهما التاثير
المناخي وثانيا مستويات الدين المتساعده
لدى الدول الفقيره ومن المهم ايجاد حل
للمشكلتين من خلال ايجاد صله وصل بينهما
ونحن في صندوق النقد نراجع الشروط التي
ستسمح بنجاح استبدال الديون باهداف مناخيه
ما توصلنا اليه هو امران اولا هناك طرق
يمكن من خلالها لبيانات التخفيف ميلان
انبعاثات ان تترجم الى اراده متواصله يمكن
التنبؤ بها ويمكن استخدامها لخدمه الدين
ثانيا يجب ان يكون هناك طريقه لتوثيق
تقليل الانبعاثات من جهه وما يعنيه ذلك
لمن يحصل على هذه الائتمالات وبالتالي من
يقبل بها لحفظ قيمه الدين اذا اردنا ان
تربط الدول بشكل موثوق التحول الاقتصادي
والعمل المناخي بتدفق المالي فاننا احتاج
الى بيانات معياريه جيده تصبح جزءا من
الحلي لازمه المناخ ونحن في صندوق النقد
نعمل على ذلك اريد ان احذر من ان الدول
التي لديها مشاكل لدينا ضخمه تتطلب اعاده
هيكله الديون فهي قد لا تكون مخوله
للاستفاده من هذه الاليه ولكن للدول التي
تريد خدمه الدين على المدى الطويل يمكنها
ربط ائتمانات الكربون من دول مال خدمه
التزامات الدين بطريقه تسمح بحل مشكله في
ان واحد
[موسيقى]
الى جانب ملف التمويل فرد ملف الخسائر
والتعويضات نفسه على اجنده قبل
اقتراح مصري في اللحظات الاخيره بعد ان
كانت تعبير المستخدم في كلاسكو لعام
الماضي هو اطلاق حوار لمناقشه الترتيبات
الخاصه بالتمويل لتجنب وتقليل ومعالجه
الخسائر والاضرار المرتبطه بتغير المناخ
ناقشت هذا الملف مع الدكتور محمود محي
الدين رائد المناخ لرئاسه المصريه في قطر
وكان هذا تعليقه
البعد الخاص بافريقيا يحتل اولويه كبرى
ولكن كما ناكد كافارقه وكعرب ايضا ومنتمي
للدول الناميه انه حتى تكون هذه القمه
افريقيه بامتياز يجب ان تركز على انفاذ
التعاهدات وممكن كلما تسير في الطرقات
الحديث مع الناس بيتكلم طيب هذه تعهدات
قديمه سواء كان التحدث بالتخفيضات او
بالتكيف همم او بالتموين همم يمكن ملف
الاضرار والخسائر كانت ايضا ومنذ دقائق تم
اعتماده ان يكون في جدول الاعمال من ناحيه
التطبيق والتنفيذ ايضا لانه مجرد ادراجه
يعني الكثير ولكن كيفيه تطبيقه هو الامر
الاهم عدد من القاده في العمل الاقتصادي
والتنموي في افريقيا منهم من المفوضيه في
افريقيا الاتحاد الافريقي وايضا من بنك من
افريقيا يتحدث ايضا عن مساله التعهدات
يجعل هذه القمه بالفع القمه لافريقيا
ولباقي الدول الناميه الحديث تكرر على ان
هذه القاره مسؤوله عن اقل من
ثلاثه% من الانبعاثات ولكن هناك خطوره اذا
ما ترك الامر على ما هو عليه
وبنقل هذه الرساله من خلالك انه هذه
الثلاثه في المئه ليست دائما لان القاره
الافريقيه لديها مواردها من النفط من
الغاز ومن ال همم ايضا من مصادر الفحم
فاذا لم يوفر التموين للطاقه الجديده
والمتجدده وان هناك نمو كبير في الاقتصاد
وحركه للتحضر بمعنى الاردنيزيشن وبالتالي
هذه الثلاثه في المئه مع زياده استهلاك
الطاقه قد تزيد عن ذلك وساعتها يلجا
العالم مره اخرى لمحاوله تخفيض
الانبعاثات كما يحاول العالم المتقدم الان
التعامل مع الصين ده 30% من انبعثات او
حاله همم الهند التي تقترب من حوالي تسعه
ولابد لافريقيا ايضا مدير قدما في برامجها
التنمويه الخاصه بها ولن تستطيع الانتظار
لزمن لزمن طويل حتى ياتي لها التمويل
الغربي بالنسبه لطاقات كل اربعه حول
العالم ليس لديهم وصول للكهرباء في ثلاثه
من الاثر في 800 مليون واحد من غير كهرباء
منهم 600 مليون في افريقيا كلهم في همم
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء همم جئتها على ذكر
موضوع مهم همم دكتور محمود فيما يخص اللصا
دامت وهي التعويضات من الخسائر والاضرار
الناتجه عن الكوارث الطبيعيه بسبب تغير
المناخي لا ننسى فقط المثال حاضر في
باكستان في الصيف كان هناك فيضانات ثلث
صحيح
من من يدفع لباكستان من الدول الغربيه
التي كان لها الباع الطويل في الانبعاثات
خلال الافكار
والخسائر التي لها الباكستان
تجاوز 40 مليار دولار الامين العام للامم
المتحده توجه بطلب للمساعده الانسانيه
العادله الى الان لم يلبي اكثر من 1% على
سبيل التعاهد 1% من 40 مليار فيجب ان
نتخيل هنا ان الباكستان التي تعاني مثل
دول ناميه كثير من الضيق في الميزان
المالي تحاول انها تاتي بتمويل جديد انا
عايز انظر لموضوع الاضرار والخسائر لتبسيط
الامر ان ده خط الدفاع الثالث خط الدفاع
الاول هو تخفيف الانبعاثات وياتي بنزع
الكربون وهمم الطاقه القديمه متجدده خط
الدفاع الثاني فشل الاول وبالفعل والاول
لم يحقق اهدافه فهو التكيف بمزيد من
الاستثمارات الاساسيه
هو ملف الاضرار والخسائر للتعويض الناس من
مشاكلهم
فاصل القصير وتابع بعده في مستقبل الطاقه
دول ليس فيها كهرباء فكيف تسال عن تخفيض
الانبعاثات
[موسيقى]
في كرتون الصوت الاخر مسموع بقوه بعيدا عن
السرديه الاحاديه للدول الاوروبيه
والغربيه عموما والتي تحمل خطابا عاطفيا
في معادلات النفط كان لي لقاء مع وزير
الدوله للشؤون الخارجيه ومبعوث شؤون
المناخ في السعوديه عادل الجبير الذي اضاء
على التناقضات في الخطاب الاوروبي بين فرض
الضرائب على انواع الوقود النفطي مقابل
دعم الفحم الاكثر تلوثا
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه الحوار بالنسبه لموضوع التغير
المناخي مليء بالمشاعر والعواطف
ويسقد المنطق والعلم
ولما يكون الحوار مليء بالمشاعر
تجد في تناقضات على سبيل المثال الدول
الاوروبيه تفرز ضرائب 200% على البترول
واحد الحجاج انه المناخ في نفس الوقت
يقدمون مساعدات للفحم الذي اسوا للمناخ من
البترول المنطقه
في عندك هناك مطالبات بعدم الاعتماد على
البترول والفحم
وبعد ما صارت الازمه في اوكرانيا صار في
مطالبات برفع انتاج الفحم والبترول هذه
المناطق هذه هذه المواقف المتناقضه
اساسها
الحوار الذي ليس مبني على منطق وعلى امور
علميه
الوقود الحفوري سوائل البترول او الفحم
حيث يستمر مع العالم على مدى عقود
التغيير ما يصير في يوم وليله الصغير
تدريجي هناك حاجه ترتفع للطاقه في العالم
انه ما نستطيع ان نلبي هذه الحاجه الا اذا
وجدنا همم مصادر طاقه مدينه
سواء كانت شمسيه سواء كانت من الرياح سواء
كانت لابد لانه الانتاج بالنسبه للبنات
البترول في حد
لا نستطيع ان ننتج اعلى منه فاذا كان
الهدف انه توفير الطاقه للعالم لابد يكون
فيه طاقه
اضافيه
المملكه
الهدف الان انه من اين نحصل على مصادر
اضافيه لتلبيه الطلب على الطاقه من قبل
العالم والمملكه همم
في هذا المجال سواء المجال همم الطاقه
الشمسيه المياه الرياح همم وغيرها من
الموارد الاساسي يكون عندك طاقه مستدامه
وتستطيع ان تلمي بحاجه المجتمع
الدولي للطاقه
[موسيقى]
الحديث عن تحول الطاقه يصبح ترفا في دول
لا تصل اليها الكهرباء اصلا ولذلك يطرح
السؤال حول الموازنه بين الاولويات
المناخيه واولويات التنميه رئيس قطاع
الاستدامه بشركه جنرال الالكترونيه
حدث على كيفيه الموازنه بين الحاجه الى
توفير الكهرباء في الدول الفقيره او التي
تعاني من الماسي وتوفير حلول الطاقه
المستدامه في الوقت ذاته
ميسي العرب
هاجر
هذا الموسم
[موسيقى]
تحدي الاخر امام شركات الطاقه الكبرى هو
التوفيق بين الحاجه الى زياده الاستثمارات
في النفط والغاز على المدائن القصير
والمتوسط بالتوازي مع الاستثمار في
الطاقات النظيفه سالت المهندس كريم امين
عضو مجلس اداره شركه سيمنز للطاقه عما اذا
كان تحقيق هذا التوازن ممكنا
احنا محتاجين نشتغل على الصعيدين محتاجين
نشتغل بالتوازي اا التكنولوجيا
التكنولوجيا الحديثه والجديده اللي لازم
توجد حلول خلينا نقول على يعني نطاق صناعي
كبير بتحتاج وقت وبتحتاج تجارب ومحتاجينها
ولازم نتحرك فيها بسرعه ولازم يحط فيها
استثمارات لكن في نفس الوقت احنا عندنا
حلول نقدر نشتغل عليها الان عندنا سواء في
قطاع النقل او في قطاع توليد الكهرباء او
في قطاع النفط والغاز همم بعض المنظمات
اللي انت تقدر بسرعه بالتكنولوجيا
المتواجده حاليا تحدث وترفع من كفائتها
وتقلل جدا البصمه الكربونيه وتوفر في
استخدامات الطاقه ما فيش شيء بيمنعنا ان
احنا نتحرك في الموضوع ده حاليا وفي نفس
الوقت نكون بنشتغل على الحلول اللي احنا
محتاجينها في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
التحدي البيئي يمكن الاستجابه له بمسارات
متعدده احدها الجواب التكنولوجي من خلال
التقنيات الحديثه الاحتجاز الكربون واعاده
استخدامه وتخزينه فالى اين وصلت تقنيه
السيسي يو اس وهل هناك افق ان تصبح مجديه
تجاريا حملت هذا السؤال الى محمد ابو زهره
الرئيس الاقليمي لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا للمعهد العالمي لاحتجاز
الكربون وتخزينه
كما ذكرت نحن بحاجه انهن ان ضاعت الكبست
بتاعه التقاط ثاني اكسيد الكربون لاكثر من
100 ضعف في حلول العشر سنوات القادمه الان
الحكومات مطلوب منها انها تعزز السياسات
والقوانين المدعمه على سبيل المثال انه
نضع قيمه لثاني اكسيد الكربون سواء سعر
همم بحيث انه يتم تداوله وبحيث انه يكون
هذا انسان طيب خاصه للقطاع الخاص انه يدخل
في مجال الاستثمار في هذه التكنولوجيا
ايضا لما نحكي عن تقنيه احتجاج الكربون
وتخزينه في اللي هي المسؤوليه طويله الامد
من المسؤول عن
الاستوريج بعد 20 سنه 30 سنه هذا يقع على
عاطف الحكومه اما انها تقننه او انه تنتقل
للمسؤوليه بعد فتره معينه للدول بحيث انها
تكون مسؤوله عن انه ما يصير ان اداره هذا
الموقع والخزان خاصه بعد همم
محمد ده يعني نتحدث قليلا عن كلفه تقنيات
احتجاز الكربون هناك تطبيقات متعدده لهذه
التقنيه ممكن نركبها على محطه كهرباء يعمل
بالفحم ممكن على بعض مصافي التكرير فهناك
هامش سعري واسع ما هو النطاق السعري وكيف
تحرك تاريخيا في السنوات الاخيره هل هناك
انخفاض في الكلفه هلا نحن في عندنا بعض
المحطات مثلا في صناعه الحديد والصلب
بيكون فيها تركيز ثاني اكسيد الكربون عالي
جدا 80% 85% هاي بتكون في اقل الكلف
الاسعار يعني في بعض المحطات ممكن تكون
التكلفه 30$ للطون ثاني اكسيد الكربون اذا
انتقلنا لمحطات توليد الكهرباء بشكل عام
سواء غاز او فحم بكون نطاق السعر بين 90
ل120$ ثاني اكسيد الكربون الان انت ذكرت
في البدايه عن التقاط ثاني اكسيد الكربون
من الهواء
هاي اسعارها بتكون اعلى بكثير يعني ممكن
تصل 400 التقنيه ناشئه ولها محفزات مختلفه
عن التقاط الكربون من من المصادر المركزه
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه من
مستقبل الطاقه عدوا القاكم الاسبوع المقبل
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]